the fourth of July is America's birthday
bash this summer ritual of picnics
parades and pageantry celebrates the
formal adoption of the Declaration of
Independence in 1776 the most cherished
document in our history it declared an
end to England's colonial rule and
proclaimed America an independent nation
that all men are created equal the 4th
of July is all about honoring this
chapter in America's past acted out in
red white and blue traditions it's a day
when offices shut down
barbecues light up and the whole country
wraps itself in the flag but if there's
one single icon that truly represents
the fourth its fireworks
fireworks have been a traditional part
of the fourth for as long as anyone can
remember
I think fireworks could be the perfect
way to celebrate it if any holiday the
sun's gone down and and and just waiting
with anticipation everyone around you
literally goes aha there are a
pyrotechnic displays in virtually every
corner of the country in fact according
to the Gallup poll in any given year
more than 60% of Americans plan to
attend a fireworks display on the
holiday and many of the most
breathtaking shows are conceived here
the Brookhaven New York home of
fireworks by Grucci
the family history of our business of
the Grucci family starts back in 1850 in
Italy with my grandfather's grandfather
the family immigrated to America in 1870
bringing their explosive secrets with
them
today four generations of grew cheese
are still active in the business
handcrafting kaleidoscopic displays that
dazzle crowds around the world they've
provided the fireworks at many of the
major celebratory events in recent
American history the Centennial's of the
Brooklyn Bridge and the Statue of
Liberty opening and closing ceremonies
of the Salt Lake City Winter Olympics
and seven consecutive presidential
inaugurations but 60% of their annual
business comes from producing shows for
the 4th of July
so you skewed the site planner with sort
of fallout zone doesn't go over the
office color correct every show gets
molded from a blank white piece of paper
and starts and builds up from that point
we are constantly blending the art form
of pyrotechnic entertainment with the
science aspect of what can or cannot be
done so every single performance that we
have is unique
you